depuis quelques jours dès qu'on allume
la télé on entend noël noël
si emmanuel macron a évoqué la date du
1er décembre pour le déconfinement on
imagine que lorsqu'on voudra sortir ce
jour là les policiers nous dirons quand
je ne crois pas non et si on a besoin
d'optimisme et de réconfort en ces temps
difficiles
inutile de s'adresser au ministre de la
santé olivier derand qui est ce qu'on
appelle un gros classeur d'ambiance noël
ne sera pas une fait normal cette année
de son côté la sncf prépare déjà l'après
en effet elle a réouvert les
réservations du 5 janvier au 28 mars
prochain et we go a même ouvert pour la
première fois des lignes reliant l'île
de france à plusieurs stations de ski
[Musique]
selon l'ifop sept français sur dix se
préparent à un noël confiné où line
vacances dans une salle c'est une des
possibilités si de nombreuses personnes
sont encore réticentes à l'idée de
réserver leurs billets pour les vacances
jean baptiste djebbari ministre délégué
aux transports s'est voulu rassurant en
précisant que les billets seront
échangeables et remboursables et bien
être un les billets d'avion que vous
achetez aujourd'hui ils sont
remboursables échangeables sans frais
alors pourra-t-on partir en vacances à
noël pour en parler bernard sabbah
spécialiste du voyage sur rtl et m6 est
avec nous ce soir
je sais que vous êtes tous en famille
est en train de nous regarder vous
attendez les réponses de bernard sabbah
courson sur agissent avec mon ami mon
frère que j'aime julien courbet bien sûr
qui est exceptionnel et j'embrasse très
fort note du jury et il le sait il me
manque
jean castex vient d'annoncer qu'il était
trop tôt de prendre c'est pourquoi de
ces billets pour noël vous vous avez
toutes les réponses vous êtes mieux que
jean castex
je vous le dis c'est vrai regardez
alors est-ce que vous conseiller de
partir ou déjà si on doit partir je
pense que déjà il faut assurer de partir
en france ou en europe ça veut dire je
pense qu'il faut partir à la neige cette
année
d'accord les stations vont être ouvertes
ou et les stations vont être ouvertes de
la course perd ça veut dire que si elle
déconfinement le 2 décembre on sera un
peu plus tranquille même si c'était le 8
ou le dise la cristallisation
commencerait le 19 décembre qu'elles
sont prêtes les stations sont prêtes les
protocoles sanitaires ont été mis en
place toutes les grandes marques se soit
maeva pierre et vacances goélia travail
ce qui est tout au mythe tout ça en
challenge vacances s'élève à côte mais
mes skis sont kasher non savez que c'est
marca qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait non
non c'est important elles ont fait payer
1 % d'acompte sur un séjour de trois
mille euros à patience et 30 euros pour
réserver c'est plutôt sympa comme des
marques comme ça moi vous n'avez pas
assez large et assurer un seul vous
allez le payer très bientôt
et là c'est intéressant parce que je
pense qu'on ne prend pas de risque dès
qu'on va sortir du déconfinement
deuxième question que tout le monde se
pose là la voir que les questions que
tout le monde se pose à des questions
tout le monde se pose pour les aura pas
il y aura-t-il suffisamment de train
pour ses vacances
oui je pense tout simplement que vous le
savez que aussi bien la sncf pour ne
parler que d'eux ou six voix on parle
des avions les gens qui sont
propriétaires des avions ou la sncf ils
ont leur train donc il me voir où je
rends rejeté au fur et à mesure
évidemment cela demande donc ça je ne
suis pas inquiet du tout là dessus pas
du tout pas du tout du tout du tout
plutôt du cloud ce taux alors prenez une
question que tout le monde se pose au
niveau des tarifs
est-ce que c'est plus intéressant qu'en
période normale ben moi je veux dire que
les prix ne vont pas changer parce qu'il
y aura évidemment plus de demande que
d'offre
et comme on a restreint la demande
d'avions on va prendre l'exemple de
destinations lointaines
tout le monde a réduit évidemment la
capacité des appareils avant on avait
des avions à 400 500 places
rappelez-vous l'airbus a380 aujourd'hui
il disparaît du marché il n'y a qu'une
seule compagne erin qu'il a conservée
donc il ya moins de place donc
évidemment les prix sont plus chers et
donc on n'aura pas de promotion pendant
les vacances ne l'espérais pas ça c'est
une hérésie
c'est une hérésie oui bien sûr d'accord
vous conseillez pas de réserver la
veille pour le lendemain pour avoir des
bons prix alors écoutez on ya toujours
des opportunités de dernière minute ça
joue la corde mais je ne crois pas aux
produits miracles cette année
maintenance sncf ils l'ont dit ils le
font là des tarifs avantageux sur une
radio ce assez pour se défouler bretons
ils le font là en ce moment
oui remboursable est quand même la sncf
c'est l'état facile pour l'état d'aller
promotionner et d'utiliser les travaux
qu'on voyage en france et qu'on dépense
en france mais très général ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça alors est-ce
qu'on peut rerentrer ont réservé à la
dernière minute c'est peut-être pas mal
il y aura des opportunités je pense
qu'entre jours et une semaine avant le
départ il y aura des risques de pâma
retient pas d'accord très bien quels
conseils pour les français est-ce qu'on
peut partir loin est-ce que s'il ya des
français qui ont envie de se faire un
qui font ils ont envie de partir aux
bahamas il dira envie de partir aux
maldives
ils ont envie de partir chez une des
fans de benjamin castaldi je crois que
benjamin castaldi de voeux doit partir
aux maldives sont nos responsables
femmes
j'ai une surprise moi ça va me bats cela
n'est plus ce qu'il peut partir aux
maldives non moi je ne conseille pas de
partir aux maldives
mauvaise idée je suis française oui
exactement il faut partir en octobre
là on n'a pas de soucis dom tom c'est
guadeloupe super mamie pas su réunion la
réunion soit les eaux rejetées
et puis surtout non mais c'est pas un
cours je vous donne c'est que je
déconseille si vous me prenez pour un
con j'étais trois ans dans le voyage ça
soit un joli un et trois dépôts de bilan
je pense que dom tom ya pas de soucis
qu'il faut penser que si elle eu moins
de problèmes évidemment à l'étranger il
faut pouvoir être rapatriés facilement
ou bien sûr qu un hôpital qui sera
équipé donc hausse c'est quand même plus
important de parano d'octobre que de
partir trop loin mais on peut partir en
république dominicaine on peut partir au
canard il y aura des destinations
accessibles d'accord très bien vrai week
est rien du tout je comprends pas au nom
confinement et là j'ai trois amis trois
connaissances qui rentrent de vacances
compris l'avion par monsieur peut pas
visiter mes parents mais je peux aller
propres en habit pour aller à dubaï il
me dorer la pilule de salariés possible
je pense que c'est là où il ya le bât
blesse c'est comme dire aujourd'hui on
utilise des documents
non-officiel ou considéré comme officiel
donc c'est une forme de trafic et donc
on voyage on j'ai vu un week-end des
amis qui sont partis à belgrade
et ils m'ont dit qu'à belgrade est
magnifique tout mon ami le masque
n'avait pas de contraintes alors donc
pour résumer croire qu'on va avoir des
prix c'est une hérésie exact partir loin
c'est vrai que c'est là où le bât blesse
donc oui à votre question oui j'ai une
question j'ai entendu dire mais vous
allez peut-être démentir que des grands
groupes qui avaient des villages de
vacances par exemple avait déjà tiré un
trait sur les vacances on parle des gros
ont des grands groupes alors la lys
l'afp les clubs quels qu'ils soient bien
dans leurs mouvements évidemment de
population étant est en danger alors que
si vous avez dans une résidence
hôtelière où on sait que des familles
vont venir à 6 à 8 maximum à 10 on l'a
vu un dans la démarche de foi et mini
sur le dit bien maximum dix personnes
savent que dans les chalets etc
on va pas voir avoir une concentration
de personnes au niveau du voyage
[Rires]
c'est un ami à lui qui chaque année voit
la cac et la grande distribution bannira
voilà pourquoi et encore j'aimerais
qu'ils me gratter sont pas allés sur un
bateau c'est ça donc voilà oui qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la réponse cinglante
de castex qui dit que le confinement ne
sera pas compatible avec le voyage
loisirs et encore moins avec le ski
alors qu'on sait que c'est 20 à 30% de
leur chiffre cette question cette
question m radio et dans un instant on
aura les yeux couleur
franchement avec tout l'aspect que j'ai
pour d'autres gouvernements et le
premier ministre que je peux dire que le
gouvernement aide énormément
les acteurs du voyage cette gare mais le
premier ministre
à mon avis sur ce coup là il va pas bien
parler parce qu'on pense qu'on ne peut
pas il n'est pas médecin
il n'a pas les capacités aujourd'hui de
dire il est pas moins castex non du tout
il n'a pas magasin de bricolage de
magasin brico la jeunesse et castex tu
veux te vois tu je prends le rabot aussi
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour lui mais
je pense qu'en tout cas il ne peut pas
deviner ce qui va se passer je pense
qu'il y aurait un confinement le 2
décembre le 8 ou le disent et les gens
pourront partir en vacances est
catégorique et il met en difficulté
toute une partie de la profession de
cherry pour moi djouhri pologne dernière
question bernard sa copa qui est
confiant du topless bientôt tout aux
maldives est ce que c'est risqué où ça
allait sortir ce qui est ce que c'est
plus simple d'avoir la double
nationalité pour pouvoir voyager
tranquille où ben oui mais vous avez la
double nationalité vous permet d
évitement de rentrer plus facilement
dans un pays mais vous savez quand le
pays est sérieux on vous fait faire 14
jours voir cette juive de conduite pour
finir on ne peut pas aller voir la
famille en question c'est ça parce que
sinon si on arrive on doit attendre 14
juste avant tout à la maison il aurait
dû à sept jours voir le cas d'israël
aujourd'hui 7 jours vous devez rester
dans un hôtel vous ne pouvez pas les
voir votre famille et à partir du
huitième jour vous pouvez avoir son
coach il ya des gens qui viennent voir
isabelle et d'en attendre sept jours ils
font comme ça et se dire est ce qu'elle
va être encore la c1
là c'est pas s'il vous plaît du côté des
arbitres nba
les opportunités sont remboursement est
prévue au point final c'est obligatoire
obligatoire depuis non mais ça c'est
important
il faut le dire que toutes les personnes
qui investissent de l'argent dans voyage
qui n'assure pas le cas dans l'
ordonnance du 25 mars au et leurs
philippe avait dit on conserve l'argent
vont bon sera si vous ne prenez pas
vraiment donné 18 mois ça c'est plus
possible c'est donc l'avenir septembre
s'est terminée par castex oui c'est
terminé dans tous les cas quand vous
verser de l'argent et qui a un
confinement vous êtes remboursé
immédiatement
regardez notre compagnie nationale elle
a fait air france protect ça veut dire
vous verser de l'argent pour un billet
d'avion
vous ne partez pas en vous rembourse
immédiatement s'il vous plaît jean
castex
je lui redirai et les annonces pour eux
c'était le soir tard sur tf6
il ya des annonces à aubry jour tu as
envie de bouffer de sexe à jean castex